good afternoon let us dwell for a moment
more in those gaps where we can make the
unseen visible and manifest latent
structures of human creativity to
discover new instances of creation in
between what we've already made so some
of what we've made lives in museums
where at any given time only 10% of a
collection may be visible but about 50
years ago a trend began to democratize
museum shows or take all of the
instances of objects that are hidden
away in warehouses and in storage and to
put them in open stacks where visitors
could see them and this first happened
in the Department of Anthropology at the
University of British Columbia and their
museum but in 1998 the Metropolitan
Museum of Art opened the Luce Center the
Henry Luce Centre for visible storage
where they did something similar and
took most of their objects of American
art that were hidden away in warehouses
and put them in this delightful visible
storage and the excellent thing is about
this visible storage is that it
challenges this relationship between
what's made in what we choose to display
for what's made represents this vast
structural language that can also be
used to describe the single instances
that we observe and so we start to
interrogate the relationship between
these two things when we walk through
these glass cases of visible storage
which have actually become quite popular
with other instances at the Victoria and
Albert Museum in England and at the
Brooklyn Museum with their famous
pitcher wall pictured here so all of the
instances here are instances of human
creativity that we can use machine
learning to infer a latent structural
model underlying all of these unique
instances and then start to build a
structural language for generating other
such instances based on what's already
been made and we had the chance in a
recent collaboration with the Met Museum
and Microsoft and MIT to put this this
thinking to the test in 2017 the Met
released an open-access catalog of over
400,000 of their their digital works
that had been scanned and they were put
into the public domain and they wanted
to use a
- both explore the context of this
collection in ways that people could
interact with and discover it and to use
it as a tool for education and so this
past year at MIT with the team from open
learning and with the knowledge futures
group we put together a collaboration
between the two Institute the between
the three institutions to see how we
could bring machine learning to bear on
the Mets open access digital collection
and so last year in December we put
together a two-day hackathon where teams
including myself in Matthew Ritchie
experimented on using machine learning
to explore the Met digital collection
and to as well see to create some new
work and then just a couple of weeks ago
we had a reveal at the beginning of
February where certain projects from
this showcase with the Met were put on
display in the Great Hall of the Met for
just one night so we can take objects
like we see here in the Mets online
collection and we can use them as
training data for world models that can
begin to infer from instances of human
creation this structural language
underlying them and so we can think
about these vast numbers of works in the
public collection as training data for a
generative model that can bet then be
used to generate new instance of work
which is thinking about existing work as
statistical instances or samples from a
model and we can create future samples
that explore the spaces between what's
already been made so here we see vases
and pitchers in the Mexica lection and
then we see interpolated Voss's or vases
that could exist based on what already
does and so to do this we found nearest
neighbors for each object in the mets
digital collection in certain categories
in large trained world models such as
began or program trained on them at
digital collection itself and we can
find sort of the closest object
corresponding to something that exists
in the latent space or the see of this
neural network that has learned
something about structure underlying
creation and then we can use this for a
couple of things we can use it to
interpolate existing collections and to
iterate them forward and so in
interpolating we can explore based on
what's already been made other objects
that could exist in those spaces between
works in a particular archive and we can
iterate
generating thousands of variations and
then selecting features that are
particularly compelling to drive the
next generation of outputs and so here
we've got a wander through the latent
space of began corresponding to sets of
objects in the Met collection and on the
right we have pairs of objects existing
objects on the left and then generated
objects on the right and you can imagine
generating thousands and thousands of
these and choosing features that you
might want to fabricate as we've seen
earlier today in real life and start to
build a complex collaborative ecosystem
where we can work with parts of our own
culture represented in parallel to us
executed lis in software such that we
can collaborate with these long trends
and collectively curated models quite
explicitly rather than having to
manifest them in instances of individual
inspiration we unlock this whole other
world of making this automatic and
making it scalable and allowing other
people to interact and iterate and
explore styles that might have been
developed thousands of years ago so we
can look at large sets of these
generated instances and they start to
inspire for me the feeling of what we
saw when we wandered through those glass
cases in the visible storage right where
when you're wandering there you might
see rows upon rows of bowls where
handles have slightly different
curvature or ceramics of increasingly
intricate patterning and when you look
at each instance just as you look at
each teapot here you simultaneously
experience its uniqueness owing to
particular parameters that were used to
generate it as well as its potential to
be iterated because you understand that
the model used to create it could be run
again so this is a very different type
of flavor of uniqueness than that of the
single work behind a piece of glass for
instance it's a uniqueness that is not
conflated with scarcity because
everything that you see here you can
remix and modulate and recreate yourself
so because we can we have the power to
remix and modulate with articulated
models for making the way I like to
think about what we're doing is creating
a shared an executable language for
aspects of human culture that
been curated across millennia and this
has the potential using machine learning
and artificial intelligence to rekindle
a very ancient relationship to making
where the creation of beauty was the
enactment of a beautiful process and the
manifestation of cultural structure that
had been collaboratively authored over
generations right in a particular region
or at a particular time with AI models
we can give people access to that and so
it's very critical that these models
become a shared resource and allow
people to interface with culture that's
collectively attended as part of the
collaboration with the Met and Microsoft
we built an online studio where people
can interact with the models underlying
the Metz collection and generate their
own instances of artwork and discover
what might lie in the spaces between
what's lying in the Metz collection
already and then move as you saw across
the map which is a spatial way of
understanding the latent space
underlying a collection rather than just
toggling features we allow people to
move through a visual depiction of space
where features are captured by one's
proximity to other objects represented
on the plane and then once you've found
a particular object that's that's
compelling you can use that to discover
other objects in the Metz collection
that are visually similar and so we're
linking these collections together and
allowing people to explore features in
their manifestation in a way that that
is executable and iterable rather than
linked to specific works that are locked
in one place in time the importance of
developing shared models and models as a
shared resource will only increase as we
start to lower the boundaries for these
long complex chains of collaboration
that collapse these traditional notions
of authorship that we have as we develop
models that have the ability to be to be
modulated and run again and to iterate
and to live in ecosystems we need new
considerations of attribution and of
authorship and we need infrastructure
for making collaborating with these
models a new norm if you'd like to
collaborate with us we've got a couple
of resources online and we also have a
set of how-tos and demos corresponding
to the Met Microsoft and MIT project on
pub pub
like to build your own studio or run
your own hackathon thank you
[Applause]
you